happy monday today we're talking about
why it's so damn hard to get an xbox
series x
how amazon is going to deal with away
from keyboard people as well as when
we're finally going to be able to play
elden ring my name is devonte chisholm
and you're watching gamespot news let's
get started with the new gen consoles
and why they're so hard to get xbox's
vice president of gaming phil spencer
recently spoke with the rap and said
finding a console isn't going to get
much easier anytime soon phil told the
site there are multiple kinds of pinch
points in the process of console making
and it comes down to more than just the
chip shortage he went on to say quote i
think regretfully it's going to be with
us for months and months
definitely throughout the end of this
calendar year and into the next calendar
year so do you have a ps5 or one of the
xbox series consoles do you love it do
you hate it how did you get it let me
know in the comments
but alright it's pretty hard to deny new
world's popularity and now nearly a week
after its launch the game has surpassed
another milestone over the weekend new
world saw more than 900 000 concurrent
players on steam making it the most
played game on the platform this
explosion of popularity has resulted in
some really long queue times for some
servers
and it's caused some players to use some
not so great methods like auto running
into a wall in order to stay on servers
and not have to reload in however
players ways of skirting around the
game's automatic away from keyboard
detection system will soon come to an
end amazon games announced it's looking
to take action to both implement better
afk detection as well as punish bad
faith afk players community manager
henry stelter said the new detection
system works but that players who are
playing the game normally should not
experience any issues
but okay with its long-awaited release
date just months away a developer at
from software has confirmed that eldon
ring is almost done being developed
during an interview with famitsu from
software's yushihiro katao plainly said
the game is quote at the end of
development although he didn't say when
the game would likely go gold catal also
loosely described the game's world and
difficulty saying players could quote
seamlessly visit the dungeons littered
throughout the game's open world as for
the game's difficulty well it's still a
from software game katau said quote high
difficulties and overcoming them are a
part of elden ring and that is exactly
why i probably won't be playing it i'll
give it a shot five minutes maybe a
little more we'll see
switching gears to epic games now
because it announced the epic
achievement system on its epic game
store starting next week players can
begin earning xp by completing epic
achievements in select titles like
rocket league hades pillars of eternity
can of bridge of spirits zombie army 4
and alan wake remastered epic is also
sending out a set of tools for
developers to easily and quickly
implement achievements for the epic game
store platform so more games will be
supported later this year and while the
epic game store already had achievements
last year they were specifically
developer achievements which were fully
owned and operated by developers on a
game by game basis the new achievement
system applies to the platform itself
much like xbox and playstation and i
love me some trophies and i can't wait
to platinum what was it called far cry 6
soon-ish you know because i know the
game is huge but this is awesome i like
collecting achievements so just give me
another platform to do it and uh you
know someone peer pressure nintendo to
do it get them on the phone
that'd be cool too and before we close
out i just want to remind you that the
final dlc reveal for super smash bros
ultimate is coming up on october 5th
sakurai posted a comment about how this
event will appeal to all video game fans
via his twitter and said quote whether
you're a smash bros player or simply
love video games make sure you tune in
and while this has fueled speculation of
who the final fighter will be when names
like sora from kingdom hearts and master
chief from halo among the most popular
guesses sakurai gave no direct hints as
to who will be joining the fight fingers
crossed still for billy hatcher i'm
telling you this is his year he's
getting in
i don't want to bet money on it so don't
ask me to but who do you want in the
game comment down below and that's it
for today i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
you